bonjour monsieur
est-ce que la réaction vérifi est à la
hauteur
bonjour monsieur Giro
parlementaire pendant 4 mois décisions
de la France insoumise à l'issue de la
condamnation du député pour violence sur
son ex-épouse s'il vous plaît
un peu plus tôt devant le palais de
justice de l'île de quand s'affrontait
des féministes
face à des militants insoumis venus le
soutenir pas d'animosité entre mais la
discussion et France le député devra
suivre également un stage de
sensibilisation aux violences faites aux
femmes Adrien cadenas qui avait été
coupé ce matin d'une peine plus lourde
qu'attendue les condamné à 4 mois de
prison avec sursis je pense que quand on
est condamné quand surtout on est d'une
famille politique souvent donné des
leçons sur ces sujets là
la moindre des choses ça serait
peut-être effectivement qu'il
démissionne le plus crédible qui n'a
plus la force morale éthique pour porter
cela et donc la question lui est posée
fortement et elle est posée à son groupe
également c'est intéressant de voir ce
qu'elle ce qu'elle disait elle un député
condamné pour violence conjugale ne peut
pas siéger il doit démissionner par
respect pour les femmes pour nos combats
et les valeurs que nous défendons s'il
avait été aux parties socialiste il
aurait été exclu du Parti socialiste
aujourd'hui en tant que député
socialiste membre de l'interview de la
nupesse nous ne souhaitons pas qu'il
réintègre nos bancs soulager je ne sais
pas si on peut l'être quand on est passé
devant une procureur de la République
dans un contexte difficile en tout cas
il est satisfait que la justice est
entendue ce qu'il avait on va dire
entendu sa vérité et qu'aujourd'hui elle
ne l'est pas empêchée de reprendre son
travail son mandat et sa place sur les
bancs de l'Assemblée nationale oui
Adrien
on va les quitter et qui parle notamment
de lynchage donc Adrien Catena ce qui
est citation
donc c'est compliqué de mettre en image
quand c'est à la presse écrite le fait
de décider d'une une radiation c'est à
dire le fait que
Adrien catin
s'il soit siéger siègera en tant que mon
inscrit me semble être une décision à
une portée peut-être symbolique mais en
tout cas une portée réelle il dénonce un
lynchage il exclut de démissionner voilà
ce qu'il est il dit j'ai endurance ce
lynchage médiatique inédit de la part de
gens qui n'étaient pas derrière les
porte-closses d'une histoire de couple
et qui ne connaissait rien nos dossiers
on peut pas dire tant que les hommes
sont pas condamnés à tomber et une fois
qu'ils sont condamnés ils reviennent
aujourd'hui il a été condamné doit
démissionner de son mandat le monde
politique n'est pas à la hauteur je vous
rappellerai qu'on a quand même sur nos
bancs un homme accusé par plusieurs
femmes de viol arrestation hier Obama de
sambankman fried 30 ans le fondateur de
l'empire de crypto monnaie en faillite
FTX c'est arrestation à la demande des
États-Unis survient un mois après
l'effondrement de la plateforme
d'échange de crypto-monnaie les Français
renoncent au chauffage leurs enfants
n'ont plus de desserts à la cantine de
piscine ou de vacances mais vive la
retraite à 65 ans ce qui nous met chacun
et chacune c'est peut-être d'abord
l'effroi moral devant cette guerre et
notre résolution collective à soutenir
l'Ukraine vous n'avez voter la remise
carburant vous n'avez pas voté les
boucliers tarifaires vous n'avez pas
voté l'aide d'exceptionnel de rentrer
donc nous n'avons pas de leçon à
recevoir madame la Présidente panneau
sur la protection du pouvoir d'achat des
Français la séance de dédicace de
François Hollande a dévié sur le molet
d'une admiratrice il faut dire que la
jeune femme a une citation de l'ancien
président tatoué là un passage culte
pour son anglais
approximatifs sont réunis à Paris depuis
ce matin pour aider l'Ukraine à passer
l'hiver la conférence internationale n'a
pas objectif également de travailler sur
le long terme et amorcer un début de
reconstruction un tatouage humoristique
désormais signé avec
[Musique]